one of the things that actually occurs
to me in this conversation is you
actually
you actually saw an opportunity in me
first and it was these small
opportunities to do this visual
content and then later i started to see
an opportunity
for you but it is kind of funny i always
think about the second part of that
story because it's the one where all the
success came from
but the first part of the story is
central to it which is you out of some
sort of
altruism or something wanted me to have
opportunities
well i saw talented guy and i saw that
the talent you're kind of spinning your
wheels and so it's like i wanted to make
sure i
as as behind the scenes i have quoted
many times for for me
uh a key principle is uh hyman roth i
always make money for my friends and so
quoting the elderly jewish gangster from
the godfather who ends up very poorly
but in any case
the the we started working together and
then
sort of the first time that we formally
worked together where we actually formed
a company together and we actually
started working together
was with truth revolt and this is now
circa 2013.
yeah so you had given me one of the best
pieces of business advice
i ever got and at the same time another
friend of mine named frank gave me a
very similar piece of advice
and it was sort of you know god wanted
me to hear it twice
you you said it much more colorfully
than he did which is you said
something along the lines of jeremy
you're
you're very good at pissing but you are
very bad at knowing which way the wind
blows
you if you would just turn and let
reality
work for you instead of you always
working against reality
i think you'd have some success and that
really resonated with me
at that time i was also realizing
something about you which was that you
needed to be famous
and that you needed a platform from
which to influence
the political conversation and i thought
that i had discovered it
because again by way of andrew breitbart
and some of our
friends of ape connections i'd become
pals with a lot of the board members at
the david horowitz freedom center
david former leftist becomes
conservative
and i saw a lot of commonality between
you and david
both fighters you know not not
both highly intellectual both great
writers but fundamentally fighters not
not think tank guys both jewish both
part of the la scene
both uh with a with a rich interest in
culture
the difference of course being that he's
50 years older than you are and i
i could see that there was going to come
a time where david would need to step
down
and he would want his legacy the freedom
center to be passed on i thought well
there isn't a better guy in the country
than ben for that job
so behind the scenes i started meeting
with board members who are also part of
friends of abe
and planting seeds about this and
getting buy-in and this goes on for
maybe 18 months
of really getting people to see that you
could be the future of
of the freedom center and then they were
working
david uh behind the scenes until one day
and this is the way all good ideas are
right one day it's david's idea
not not mine that you could be the heir
at the freedom center and he calls you
and gives you this opportunity
with truth revolt and you and i at that
time create
yeah to your point we created our first
company within
within the freedom center within the
freedom center and it actually saw some
initial
pretty significant success and we
learned some really important lessons
from that one
among those lessons were luck is not a
business strategy because we had
designed a website and very much we were
hunting for drudge links at that time
which was one way that conservatives
would
would try to generate traffic off of no
budget was if you get a link from drudge
it explodes your traffic
right and so we would try to get links
from drudge and we realized that
sometimes the gods were generous and
sometimes they were not
uh and uh and the other thing that we
learned is that you have to
find you have to find an audience that
is capable of understanding that the
business pitch so
well this is when you gave me my
nickname i believe uh which is
the stupid whisperer this is because
you and i would always pitch people our
ideas and
you would come in and you would bend
shapiro all over them you would
use harvard words uh at 2a like
you are a podcast turned up to 2x just
in regular life right you know in terms
of the speed of your
and and these people would just sort of
look at you with these blank
doe-eyed expressions and then the stupid
whisperer would come in
and he's off texas lilt yeah that texas
come out real slow
sock puppets and i would explain your
ideas to them and they'd be like
oh yeah yeah it was very frustrating i
mean i remember walking out being like i
don't understand they understand what
he's saying but they have no idea it was
like i was speaking swahili he's barely
using
english they understand him they don't
understand anything but it turned out
that no matter whether it was
me or whether it was the stupid whisper
there are certain people who are just
not capable of
receiving these ideas and we both know
who we're talking about here uh
this is when you wrote our business plan
on a cocktail napkin
this is uh well now to be fair you came
up with a business plan so
jeremy was the one who who cracked the
code of not only
you know sort of we need to invest in
making people in our movement not just
me but generally
more famous we need to we need to
actually use the tools at our disposal
and you're the first person to really
discover the magic of social media and
how important social media was because
most of us were spending our days you
know
whittling away on twitter yeah but you
were the first person who said wait a
second there's a whole other world of
social
media we really need to get involved so
at this point you can take over the
narrative yeah i mean the idea was we
should be marketing first right and
social media presents the opportunity to
do that
and of course the freedom center and
therefore truth revolt were a non-profit
they were always struggling to figure
out how to pay for us because one of the
problems in conservative nonprofits
is that no matter how successful a
particular initiative is
its ultimate success is determined by
whether or not people will keep giving
you money for it and unfortunately when
you go to the same donors year after
year you have to give them something new
so we had had a lot of success in that
first year or so of truth revolt
but what was the story we were going to
take to donors next and i said well
here's an idea instead of taking them
year after year what if we had kind of a
for-profit model within the non-profit
universe
where we could use ad revenue and the
enormous traffic available to us through
marketing on social
to pay for all of this and then we're
not beholden to the donors
and now even the stupid whisperer could
not talk slow enough
for for certain people to understand it
and we're in this big meeting one day
and this very wealthy
very uh elderly benefactor of of
conservative think tanks
said you know essentially he said i need
you to explain this to me in even
simpler terms and we'd explained it
about seven times around oh yeah
and ben turns over a cocktail napkin
takes a pen and you drew uh
an f for facebook well it was okay so it
was dollars
dollar sign okay arrow dollar sign error
f for facebook
for facebook arrow website arrow back to
dollar sign
right and that was and i said this is
our best this is our business plan and
yeah they fired us yeah they they
defunded us they fired you i quit in
solidarity that's fair they fired me
yeah well they still wanted me to stick
around so they could uh you know pretend
that i was still associated but i had
been
relegated off to the gulag somewhere you
know wasn't actually given the death
sentence i was just sort of glue and i
was like okay that's not what we're
doing
so instead the funny thing is we had
both bought houses like one month before
this well i mean it bodes very poorly
for our move
because literally every time in our
careers we've bought houses something
cataclysmic has happened that's like
nearly almost immediately so yeah at
that point
we decided that we're going to take that
business plan and go to market yeah
and uh and you were really the driving
force here because you found that the
people who decided to
actually take a flyer on us well our the
third part of our triad right caleb
our business partner co-ceo of the
company i've been working with caleb at
that time he he was working with a high
net worth family out of texas
and they're trying to get involved in
culture and like mark masters and many
others
before through whatever political
connections they got connected to me and
then i tried to talk them out of
spending their money on culture
because i wanted them to maintain some
of their money
and during this period of time i'd
really hit it off with caleb and
uh and when we lost that job at the
freedom center i i called him and said
listen i know you're trying to get
involved in culture
i said i think there is a path for
conservatives to create
entertainment but i think you have to go
the roundabout way i think
i basically gave him the same plan that
i had pitched to you and then to others
which was
we need a marketing mechanism a
marketing and distribution mechanism
that allows us to actually put an
audience on the target because hollywood
will never cooperate
even if you manage to make a great film
they'll never cooperate
they'll make it very difficult for you i
said i think with ben
and with what we've been doing at truth
revolt evolved with this cocktail napkin
business plan
that we can make something that's
capable of marketing
whatever we produced thereafter for for
this particular audience
and he got the vision right away thank
god because i don't know how we were
going to pair mortgages
you probably had some savings at that
time because you're
a more rational fellow than i am i had a
nicer car though
fortunately caleb quickly got the vision
and and he
and he went to the high net worth family
with whom he was working at that time
and and they took it they took a risk on
us
they gave us they committed to give us
seven and a half million dollars
to start the daily wire we didn't take
the money up front we didn't want it
that way we wanted
uh for them to just pay the expenses of
the company month after month
up to the seven and a half million
dollar mark
and at month 14 we were 4.7 million
dollars
in and we became cash flow positive we
never took the rest of that money
and we've never gone back and taken any
many sense i mean since then we've grown
this company
off of that cocktail napkin business
plan now it's
it's fair to say and i think caleb would
interrupt here if you were here and to
say
it got a little bit more sophisticated
than the cocktail napkin it did and it's
amazing when we look back at the
original projections which places we
thought would be centers of revenue
attracts places we did not so certain
places
that we thought would be centers of
revenue certainly our centers of revenue
but one area that we had no idea was
going to be a center of revenue was the
actual podcast
that's right like when when we i looked
back at that business plan
and what we had allocated for the amount
of revenue from the podcast was
minimal compared to how successful the
podcast became so it just shows you you
know
all you can do is sort of plan for the
possibility of success and then you push
where there's actual
mush right you push you push where
there's actual give you know i i
responded to a tweet from
cernovich a few weeks ago he every now
and then when he
isn't posting politics he'll actually
post kind of aspirational business
uh ideas and and they're quite good i
can't remember exactly what he had
tweeted but it was something about
success and failure in business and i
responded with with what i think is the
greatest lesson i've learned in this
journey that we've been on
which is that your success in business
ultimately it doesn't come down to the
quality of your plan
it doesn't come down to your ability to
avoid
catastrophe doesn't come down to your
ability
to systematize success all of those
things matter but
none of them are what determine
ultimately long-term success long-term
success in business
is just your ability to fail
maneuver and keep moving i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the ben shapiro
show sunday special if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content